i i got a question is the gutter oil
stuff true you know about gutter oil
oh uh yeah that was definitely something
that was happening inside of china
wow do you want to explain to people
what the gutter oil thing was ah
what was it was people were i think vice
did a documentary about that's why i
learned about it
so they were basically taking used oil
and kind of from the sewer
from the sewer and then straining it and
reusing it
yeah as they were videos yeah i couldn't
quite stomach
often we make the other member of our
team matt
do the watch the things we don't want to
watch we made him watch the hunter bite
and sex videos oh no
oh jesus i think we scarred him for life
yeah well so
so i saw those i remember watching a
video about this gutter oil
and what was happening people found
essentially free
so they would take you know scooping
devices of some sort and go into the
sewer lines and scoop out refuse
and then strain the oil out of it boil
it and then use it to cook food and sell
street food
and people get sick from it guaranteed
because it's uh my understanding is that
it wasn't even necessarily food oil
it was just oil so they might be using
oil from you know
spilled out of a car or something and it
mixes in they boil it down and they cook
with it
people eat it the chinese communist
party just like blew up any kind of rule
of law
within the country and so it just became
really horribly corrupt i think the
gutter oil thing
too is like one reason why chinese
people don't actually trust
a lot of the food in china and so it's
been regulated now so i think it's not
as big of a problem as it was a few
years ago
but um i don't know if you know about
like the milk powder scandal that
happened back no
milk powder scandal um these babies were
having like
weird deformed heads and stuff like that
and it turned out that like
these farmers were putting melamine like
the plastic
melon like melanin to make the protein
levels look higher
somehow like whatever test they were
using for protein
like melamine could fake the protein
level so they were buying kind of like
extra melamine shavings from factories
and
putting them in the milk and it was
making babies really sick and killed a
few of them
kidney stones like problems and they
first of all covered up this whole thing
because it was happening right before
the olympics
so they covered up this for as long as
they could and then it kind of broke
right after the olympics happened
and then chinese people were like
outraged they executed the head of
china's food and drug administration
because someone had to take the fall it
also created a lot of tension between
mainland china and hong kong because as
chinese people knew about this they
started going to hong kong
in mass to get baby powder
same with australia and new zealand they
started like chinese people would go
buy like formula and stuff from
australia new zealand in bulk
so that you could not actually get it if
you wanted it for your baby in australia
i remember being in hong kong and
being like why are all these people
walking around with suitcases
and why is there no baby formula
anywhere and why are they buying it up
all the time and and then that story
broke and it was a huge controversy but
you see a lot of these kind of stories
with fake meat with fake fruit
fake vegetables what are some of the
most shocking ones that haven't made the
headlines in the united states that you
guys picked up on that really raised
your eyebrows
to say holy cow this is crazy
hey specific food well the thing that
comes to mind it's not quite that but
just thinking of covering up everything
that's happening with the coronavirus
yeah essentially happened with sars
it was the same thing outbreak of the
disease they tried to cover it up it
spread around
and actually this is the main reason why
taiwan has done so well with the
coronavirus is because
they suffered really badly from sars so
they they basically establish a team
that like was permanently set to like
monitor
the outbreaks of infectious disease
within mainland china and so
back in december they were already like
raising warning flags about
hey something's kind of spreading around
maybe we should be on guard
whereas the rest of the world being very
uh financially invested in china
did not have uh was was not paying any
attention to that
uh that's not quite as exciting as milk
but uh i got i got a photo i googled the
photo okay
i've got her oil oh i've seen this is
crazy
it's a woman and she's got it's like a
long stick with this like
it's a big ladle basically yeah and
she's got a bucket she's pulling
sewage it's she's lifted a sewer cap
up and she is pulling sewage out and
they were filtering it boiling it and
serving it to people yeah wow
you know i think back to the days of
snake oil in the wild wild west you see
this is why i'm kind of a liberal and
i'm okay with the regulation because i
you know i know the story about the the
cuyahoga river the you know the fire
burst in the river and we gotta
you know clean up our water clean up our
environment this is the kind of stuff
that nightmares are made of when
it's just unrepentant it's just corrupt
it's just
power by any means necessary yeah
actually that makes me
what was it up in sinclair the the was
it the jungle the jungle yeah yeah but
probably that picture does more than
like anything we've talked about
like just look at them look at gutter
oil from human
no it hits you in your stomach yeah yeah
i i
yo yeah i remember it was it's it's
there's a video from radio free asia i
think
going back to 2013 or so where they show
the process of making this and that
that's crazy to me
yeah i mean i think they've they
realized that that was like a really
bad pr thing for them but there's
probably a bunch of things like that
still going on to this day
we just haven't learned about well
there's the wet markets that the chinese
government said that they were getting
rid of because it could have been
potentially where the coronavirus came
from
and now the wet markets are back right
now which is another important aspect
that people need to understand yeah so
well so this is this is important can
you guys break down what the wet markets
are
i mean largely it's like just a normal
kind of
outdoor market play a critical role in a
lot of people's lives
because there's not like in terms of
like the food supply chain a lot of
people actually
buy food from the wet markets is it just
it's like what like they have
meats and foods out on like yeah yeah so
like a lot of it
is most most of it is just vegetables or
like meat or whatever
some of it is like living animals so you
like in china a lot of poultry markets
they're like live chickens or whatever
and then you get a chicken they'll kill
it for you
um but then some of these wet markets
have like weird exotic animal stuff
like bats yeah uh pangolins or
yeah like different i think because
people were for saying that like the wet
market and wuhan didn't sell bats so but
maybe it
went through to a pangolin basically but
like
there are and there was like a famously
like a picture going around of like a
board
at from this web market talking about
like how you could get like crocodile or
like
all these different like exotic animals
but like that's not
like that's kind of like not most of
what
what markets are so wet markets are kind
of necessary for their like
for chinese people to get food yeah but
the food but like the kind of like
exotic animals like living exotic
animals and stuff like that that's where
you
the poultry too um that's been a problem
with
like avian flu in the past so that's
where you can
get into the trouble where like weird
diseases could come up hey wouldn't it
have been nice if there was an
independent investigation into the
origin of the coronavirus yeah sure
i was going to ask you guys where what
do you think happened because the
official story according to the
uh the communist government is that this
was the wet market there's some people
speculating that this was because of the
gain of function research that was
happening at the woohand laboratory
there's other people making up other
theories what do you guys happen
what do you guys think happened uh
specifically with china
well specifically in leaked internal
documents from
the world health organization showed
that they made a deal not to investigate
the origin
wow right the wet market
was like they don't say it's the wet
market anymore like actually what
they're trying to do
is blame every other country they can
instead yeah
they're saying australia right it came
from australia from italy it came from
italy
maybe it came from frozen food that was
imported into china like
they're just trying to they don't even
say it's the wet market anymore
uh i mean i think at first i thought
well it's pretty
likely it did come from a wet market
because that's what's happened
multiple times with bird flu right and
sars was a similar situation
but um you know it seems that there have
been
earlier outbreaks than what was
associated with the wet market outbreak
so it's not really clear anymore they're
covering it up and this is the reason
why they're going so hard against
australia now
well one of the reasons they're going is
australia but they were asked they were
demanding an international independent
investigation
makes sense and they hit australia hard
i i was reading about the spanish flu
the 1918 uh flu
uh pandemic please don't call it the
spanish flu it's you know
diseases happen everywhere she should do
that you're right you're right you're
right i'm sorry
well uh interestingly there's a there's
several theories about where it actually
came from
and so the two leading theories it
actually wasn't spain
it was uh it came there was there was
world war one basically and you had
a lot of people were in the trenches
they were dirty they were sick they were
injured so when they came back to the
u.s they were bringing it with them
and it actually started to mutate and
expand and get really really worse a
whole lot worse in the us
but uh some have said it came from china
and the evidence for that they say is
that china did not experience
they didn't get hit hard by the the flu
pandemic and the reason they think
is that it originated in china as a
weaker strain
the chinese people gained a herd
immunity to it
it made its way to you know through
europe to the us and by the time the
mutated strain had come back to europe
they already had
herd immunity to that similar strain so
they were less impacted by it
it's interesting to even you know go
back a hundred years now
there are academics who are saying you
know especially chinese economics saying
that's not true you're lying you know
it was you you're dirty and things like
that i had a moment where it was like
100 years ago wasn't 1918.
um but uh
yeah just uh china back then was also an
entirely different
yeah that was before the communist
revolution right
yeah and i think an issue people
sometimes have is like they conflate
all of china's 5 000 years of history to
what the communist party is doing
right right right which is which is
grossly inaccurate the chinese communist
party is you know
communism is a western ideology that
came to china
and basically it's the dark ages
wasn't that didn't something happen
where they melted down all of their like
uh
plowshares and the greats
that's where they did that what was that
all about why did they do that well so
mao wanted to
increase uh steel production and so
there was this insane thing where just
everyone like everywhere like in
hospitals and schools they were all
melting down metal to make steel and it
was
not like steel you could use it's called
what was it
steel yeah pig iron that's it yeah and
like it was completely useless you can't
make a walk into like
steel beams that you can use for
anything yeah and because it was like
this you know
top-down state mandated thing farmers
like had to keep up production and so
they like there were issues of them just
like using their
farm tools and then
starved there was many reasons the
famine happened yeah
from the sparrow campaign where they
killed all the sparrows because they the
sparrows ate the seeds and so you got to
kill all the sparrows the sparrows also
ate the locusts
the the culture revolution was when they
started purging all of the traditional
that came after
yeah yeah so so uh can you explain the
culture evolution
mao basically felt that he was losing
control of the party politically
so he um announced that like the party
had kind of lost its way
that like the party was becoming too
bourgeois so they needed a cultural
revolution
within the communist party to kind of
purge the party of counter-revolutionary
elements
and he gave power to the red guards
which hadn't existed before there are
kind of these groups of like young
people who are
you know basically worship mao so he
basically used the red guards to
um so he could take power from the
people that he felt
in the political system who were trying
to like take
he was also very paranoid so he felt
that they were trying to take power from
him
so he used the red guards to basically
uh
cause chaos in society and like there
are different factions of red guards and
they would fight each other in the
streets
um you know like the whole chinese
society ground to a halt essentially
it's kind of hard to like talk like for
anyone who wouldn't live
through the cultural revolution to kind
of like get the real flavor of it i've
heard described from
chinese people who lived through it like
we went crazy for 10 years
yeah i mean it was really much worse in
the beginning and then towards the end
it kind of started to peter out a little
bit more
my parents were both alive during the
cultural revolution and
um they would talk about it but like
they wouldn't really talk about
like all the bad things that happened
for a long time and then they started
when i was like a teenager
actually talking about like my mom said
she watched
the students in her she was in
elementary school she watched other
students
tie her teacher up wow and beat her
what because like you know any authority
figures
were considered like you know possible
counter-revolutionaries or there were
different phases of it where like
you could be a writer or you could be a
counter revolutionary you could be
like you could be like there could be a
lot of things that like unfamiliar you
know
yeah well definitely you know you could
be a like if you were a fascist
you if you were you were like oh you you
might be related to a landlord like if
your
family used to own land before the
communist revolution
then you were you know like you're like
a black
force like there were all of these kmt
at one point
how many people died during this period
and do you see any parallels with what's
happening culturally in the united
states i well i do think the cultural
revolution
like nazi germany is a point in history
that like we should all
learn something from because how a
society gets to that point
it's it's it's something we all need to
be on guard for because
it was people were killing are we are we
on track to that point
well so for example like one of the like
people would call like somebody a
counter revolutionary
and like i think it was nobody really
knew what that meant it was just like
that's the bad thing
yeah or yeah or like how some people use
far right what does that mean
right alt right you had people spying on
each other
you had like neighborhood committees
that were set up specifically to
watch whether anybody was getting out of
here had to be
of their children you had children who
like children were taught
in schools to like spy on their parents
to see if they were
counter-revolutionary and
you know you had people who actually
denounced their parents to the red
guards and the red guards killed
their parents and they thought that they
were doing the right thing
that's creepy stuff well we all know
about you know germany
during world war ii but when you look at
the lives lost
then and when you compare it to the
chinese cultural revolution and the leap
forward it's it's
insignificant uh what are the estimates
what are the numbers because i know
there's a lot of debate uh specifically
going around how many people passed away
during this period of time
what do you think it is well it depends
on who you listen to for example uh
according to chinese communist party the
great leap forward there was there was
no great famine
that caused it was a couple years of bad
weather no it was it was called the
you know it was like three years of
natural disasters
so it was like it wasn't mao's fault you
know it wasn't the party's fault it was
totally a man-made disaster
but like if you listen it's like you
know years of natural disasters like it
wasn't our fault
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time